[Music]
first
as always these days covert let's start
by looking at the latest covert data
the vaccine rollout seems to be
continuing at pace
uh cases hospitalizations they're all
falling
so is it all pretty much good news now
kate over to you
thanks andrew taking a look at cases
first we continue to see a retreat of
this virus across the uk
hovering right around where cases were
in early december just as england was
coming out of its second lockdown
a similar story is playing out with
hospitalizations which currently mirror
where
we were in mid-december and when we're
looking at this chart we do have to
remember that a lot of those people
are under the age of 65. and if we look
at deaths the seven day rolling average
for copa deaths is falling as well
back to the levels we were experiencing
several weeks before we hit the peak
of the latest wave of the virus now
i'm wary of hope these days andrew but
if you were feeling hopeful
you look at the vaccine race and you
think that this might just be the last
time
that we're presented with charts uh so
stark and
and so dismal as the ones that we've
been looking at for the past few weeks
because as the death rate falls the rate
of people being inoculated
goes up and up and this means people
with jabs
should be broadly speaking protected
from severe illness from this virus in
the future
and as you can see here the uk is still
storming ahead of its european
counterparts with over with over 13
million people
now having received at least their first
dose of the vaccine
and i'm also delighted to report based
on the spectator's vaccine tracker
that the uk isn't just set to hit its
target by the 15th of february
it's currently on track to do so two
days early which would be this saturday
we'll see if we get this surprise early
delivery but this all but guarantees
that when spectator tv
airs next week every person over the age
of 70 will have been offered a vaccine
and will be on to the next phase of
inoculating
the next priority groups understandably
the more good news we get the more
people want to know about what it means
for reopening and this is really
difficult because the government simply
hasn't laid out
its criteria for lifting restrictions
this is a chart that was produced a few
weeks ago by the coven 19
actuaries response group now this chart
estimated that we would hit the 15th of
february target
which we are on track to do that
vaccines would be roughly 70
effective and the recent data we have
around the vaccines being used in the uk
is that their efficacy rate meets this
criteria
what it didn't account for was whether
or not vaccines could in addition to
protecting people
from the virus stop them from
transmitting the virus as well
and we don't have anything conclusive on
this front but some recent data for the
oxford vaccine
suggests that it can reduce transmission
by about two-thirds
so actually you can see the chart being
updated to reflect a more positive
scenario
but the point is that what we're set to
achieve in a matter of days
should according to this modeling
reduced deaths by roughly 85
in the next six weeks and hospital
emissions by 60
in the next six weeks now you'll note
that icu emissions don't go
down as much but we know that in terms
of who's in the icu right now
a lot of those numbers are made up by
the under 65s who haven't been offered
the vaccine yet
of course these people are also more
likely to leave the icu and
and make a full recovery but even if
this modeling turns out to be broadly
right
that's still a very meaningful shift yet
we just don't know what level of cases
hospitalizations or deaths the
government's willing to tolerate
to start restoring some freedoms and
they're not giving anything away
apart from the target of the 8th of
march when they're hoping they can start
to reopen schools we are in the dark
as to what might happen in the months
ahead yesterday you had the transport
secretary and even the prime minister
refusing to commit to foreign holidays
this year but also domestic
holidays being possible over the summer
so
it's really hard because what we're
seeing right now is actually more
measures coming in
even though more and more people are
becoming protected from the virus
the uk has adopted a stricter quarantine
policy in recent days it's going to be
implemented from next monday
mostly done in the name of preventing
new strains from entering the year
from entering the uk which they fear
could undermine vaccine efficacy
as you can see from this chart
unfortunately the data around air
passenger travel is only produced
quarterly by the home office
so we won't know how recent policy will
affect travel for some time
but you can see here that travel has
dropped off significantly
from the first lockdown never coming
close to recovering last summer
where it was before the uh before
lockdown started in
march last year the prime minister and
prime minister's questions yesterday
said that we were down to about 20 000
passengers a day
some arriving into the uk some are
saying this still
isn't low enough others are questioning
the human impact of these travel
restrictions
even for emergency reasons making it
near impossible to travel
all of this at the moment anyway being
done so in the name of a
hypothetical uh mutant strain that the
vaccines won't respond to
at all uh the world health organization
bolstered the uk strategy
this week when it recommended the oxford
vaccine be used
for all age groups above 18 including
the over 65s
good news for the oxford vaccine good
news for the uk strategy
but we simply don't know what it means
yet for restoring our liberty
[Music]
you